انضم الينا
من تل ابيب نجوان سمري ونعود الى الاخبار
العاجله التي تتحدث عن ان هناك قتيلان من
الضباط
و و تقول ايضا بان رتبه الضابط الاخير هو
رائد من وحده النخبه شل داغ في معارك شمال
غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي اذا يعترف بمقتل
ضابطين وجنديين واصابه 10 في المعارك خلال
الساعات ال 24 الماضيه هل هناك من وسائل
اعلام اخرى غير الجيش الاسرائيلي تتحدث عن
هذه الارقام
نجوان نعم بطبيعه الحال كافه وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه تنقل هذا البيان
للناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي الذي صدر قبل
قليل ويتحدث عن مقتل ضابط اخر من وحده
شلدا خلال المعارك تحديدا في شمال قطاع
غزه ليضاف هذا الضابط الى ضابط اخر كان قد
اعلن عنه صباح اليوم المتحدث الاسرائيلي
قتل ايضا بالاضافه الى جنديين قتل ايضا
خلال المعارك في شمال قطاع غزه وفي جنوب
قطاع غزه وظهر هذا اليوم اعلن ايضا الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي عن اصابه لعشره من
الضباط والجنود في المعارك الدائره في
مواقع ومناطق مختلفه وكان ايه قد تم رصد
السيارات الاسعاف العسكريه هذا اليوم وهي
تقوم بنقل مصابين تحديدا في منطقه مدين او
من منطقه مدينه غزه الى المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه بعد قليل بطبيعه الحال سيصدر
ايضا تحديث من المستشفيات الاسرائيليه
التي تم نقل الجنود المصابين اليها هذا
اليوم تحديدا مستشفى سوروكا في مدينه بئر
السبع وهذا المستشفى تحديدا هو من استقبل
وقدم العلاج لاكبر عدد من ال الجنود الذين
اصيبوا في اي قطاع غزه باعتباره المستشفى
الاقرب الى منطقه غلاف غزه الى جانب
مستشفى برزلاي في مدينه عزقلان هذا
الاعلان اليوم لمقتل اربعه من الجنود ي
يثير الع او نبدا نلحظ ان هناك حديث لدى
المراسلين الاسرائيليين الامنيين
والعسكريين عن هذا ال العدد احد المراسلين
العسكريين هذا اليوم في اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي تحدث عن انه اليوم باتمام 117
يوما لهذه الحرب تصبح هي اطول حرب تخوضها
اسرائيل وحتى انها تتجاوز الحرب التي
خاضتها في لبنان الحرب ال الاولى في لبنان
ويقول بان حتى من حيث عدد ال القتلى
للجنود فهي ربما الحرب يعني العدد الاكبر
منذ النكبه او حرب الاستقلال كما يسميها
الاسرائيليون عام 48 وهذا ربما لافت جمال
بان المحللين وال او المراسلين للدقه
العسكريين في اسرائيل عاده فقط يعني
يصرحون بتصريحات تتعلق ببيانات الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي وقلما ينتقدون ما يجري
في هذه العمليات لكن بدانا نلحظ في الايام
الاخيره الماضيه بان حتى المراسلين
العسكريين الذين
يتجندون بشكل مطلق للروايه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي تصدر عن الناطق تصدر عن
الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي هذا اليوم
كتب المراسل العسكري في اذاعه الجيش
تحديدا بان هذه الحرب بدات تشبه حرب
استنزاف
وبدات وتحولت الى اطول حرب تخوضها اسرائيل
بهذا اليوم عندما تجاوزت ال
117 يوما منذ بدايتها وهذا ربما ينضم الى
اصوات كثيره اخرى كان قد بدا يتحدث عنها
محللون في البدايه ومسؤولون امنيون سابقون
عن ان هذه الحرب بدات تطول و وبطبيعه
الحال طيله الوقت هناك ايه توجيه اتهامات
لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو وايضا
لجهات اخرى سواء كان على المستوى السياسي
وعلى المستوى العسكري لكن تحديدا هذه
الاتهامات توجه لبنيامين نتنياهو بان لديه
مصالح شخصيه
وحزب من اجل الحفاظ على وضعيته في سده
الحكم من جهه وايضا لحمايه نفسه من
تحقيقات مستقبليه تتعلق بالحرب و بهجوم
السابع من اكتوبر من جهه ولكن ايضا تتعلق
بمحاكمته السابقه في قضايا الفساد فانه
يريد اطاله امد هذه الحرب
جوان سمبري في تلبيب شكرا لك حتى اللحظه